my man
[Music]
okay Iggy is everyone confused what was
that ah that is a piece of legend though
they was big
okay the other guy was the can whip that
thing was huge
go yeah I can sprint while crawling good
golly that thing was gigantic just
mirror the rooms holy balls sad thoughts
oh my god I can't see okay go look at
the floor
what is it is it
[Applause]
this oh oh here do it locked up off gosh
darn it oh where is he
where is it he's gonna come back why why
I have so many questions that look like
a clown or something
I'm awfully lucky that I managed to get
that on the first try I don't know if
there's a time limit I don't know if
there's like a monster
[Music]
[Applause]
sis okay that's helpful come on it's
gotta be here it's gotta be premade
textures and objects and environments
you have to create everything on your
own and you may be like thinking
someone's screaming in the distance you
must be in pain from the amount of blood
that he's losing I think he is gonna
give me a hug okay I don't know what to
do about this Oh what that are you
creeping along today to do
I'm just looking over here no dude what
I was that green light red light green
light red light green light red light
red red light red light I'm going around
screw you sis and I could like see
forever how did I lose you I'm just my
pan in a 360 do I find you
then it's like Oh locked on target
[Music]
this has been the random horror reaction
compilations thanks for watching if you
liked what you son you want to see more
why not subscribe to my channel want to
help the channel grow please leave a
like added to your favorites or share it
with your friends on Facebook and
Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]